conocido el resultado final de las
elecciones presidenciales se sacan
varias conclusiones entre ellas esa baja
participación del 48% que es la más baja
en la historia de la república islámica
en unas elecciones presidenciales a esto
se le suman los más de 4 millones de
votos nulos algo que nunca se había
visto en la historia de la república
islámica en el pasado lo máximo habían
sido un millón doscientos mil votos
nulos pero en aquel momento la
participación era del 70 por ciento lo
que los analistas han interpretado como
un mensaje de la población no solamente
hacia el gobierno de hassan roja ni a la
mala situación económica e incluso a los
reformistas en quienes ya no confían
nunca más sino en el mismo sistema de la
república islámica hay un gran mensaje
que seguramente las autoridades tendrán
que leer y tendrán que tomar medidas
sobre ellas en los próximos meses hoy
también se reunió al presidente saliente
hassan rohan y con el jefe de la
justicia y nuevo presidente y va ebrahim
raisi para felicitarlo y lo mismo han
hecho diferentes mandatarios mundiales
que han
sus felicitaciones a rise y entre ellas
el el presidente ruso vladimir putin